Oh Heaven Sent penultimate episode of
series 9 of Doctor Who holy crap I love
this thing from the word go I love that
the doctors completely on his own I
don't remember ever seeing an episode
where the doctor was completely on his
own I'm sure somebody who's slightly
more versed in everything that has ever
been done with doctor who will correct
me if that's the case but I've certainly
never seen that before
they just have the laser focus on him
cuz the doc the doctor is pretty much
always the most interesting thing going
on in his stories and sometimes he's a
bigger part of the screen times
sometimes it's a smaller part of the
screen time but I always want more time
with the doctor and this is every second
is with the doctor I I love this I love
how he's just behaving in a way that
we've never really seen before and
getting a little bit of insight into his
thought process and the way that in sort
of his mind he freezes time as he tries
to think his way out of a situation
where he should die but he's like no I
know I survive this now let's figure out
how I thought the nods to Clara were
nice and they were actually more moving
to me than her actual death was last
episode and I praised the way that they
handled that but it was a little cheesy
when the actual moment came this is
showing the impact of it the weight of
it the little callbacks when she finally
showed her face cuz I didn't think that
was actually gonna happen in this
episode it was touching it was moving it
worked I love the mystery around this
thing I just love how you're watching
going what is going on and I want to
know but personally I was I was kind of
afraid to find out the answers cuz the
best mysteries the answers are almost
never as good as what the mystery sort
of built it up in your head to be this
this worked because it knew the right
things to still keep mysterious I can
that creature whatever it was I mean it
was from his nightmares we got that
reference but we never get a clear look
at it thank God but it's this creepy it
doesn't stop it keeps coming we get its
view on the screens the flies the fact
that ultimately we find out it's just
confession to
and that's how it gets his confessions
from it then oh my god and it's one of
the things that I always love about
Doctor Who is that he is he is smarter
than me he is always supposed to be
smarter than me and then realizing
slowly during that ending montage
realizing what it was he was actually
doing because when that one touch starts
you think well he's just he's just
trapped forever and this this is his
hell he's never gonna get out of it and
you think he's kind of resigned himself
to that and then as he gets like a word
or two further into that story each time
and I realized what it was he was doing
I had the biggest grin I choked up that
was an amazing moment to realize what it
was he was actually doing and that it
went from just feeling like such a
defeat like he was just doing because
there was nothing else for him to do and
he can't allow himself to stop to
realizing he had a plan and that it was
working and was going the whole time
that oh wow I know I've just been
gushing about this episode this is a
fantastic as our episode and like the
few points that I thought I was ahead of
the thing like I know I pretty much
realized that as soon as he put on his
own clothes and put the ones that he had
that were wet back in the same position
I'm like there's gonna be a loop feature
into this so that for a second made me
think I was ahead of the episode but
clearly when we got to the end I wasn't
and I was so happy to realize I wasn't
there really isn't a beating this thing
that I would change it is so masterfully
fantastically executed this is a
one-of-a-kind episode like the only
thing I'm nervous about has nothing to
do with this episode but just where do
we go from here because where it picks
up I've I don't know if I've actually
said it in this channel or any of these
videos before like I'd like the idea of
him pursuing Gallifrey kind of endlessly
I'm not sure I ever want to see him
actually find it it looks like maybe now
he has now that said that's still a
great capper on this episode it does
make me nervous for how do we pick up in
the next episode and have it live up to
what we just got with this I'm gonna
make my own call that Rassilon is behind
this I'm saying that partially hopefully
I would really love to see Timothy
Dalton come back but me we will see and
this sort of answer that we got for the
hybrid which basis
that the prophecy is wrong actually kind
of takes the curse off the whole thing
for me a bit I brought it up a couple
times that I didn't like the whole idea
cuz just because I don't like prophecies
I think they're very lazy storytelling
device basically to realize well no it
was wrong in the first place actually
for me love it that that fixes so many
of the lingering things that were
bugging me across the season up to this
point seriously guys this episode is
amazing easily now my favorite episode
of this particular series definitely
probably makes a top 10 of my favorite
episodes for new era Doctor Who all
together so you know what let's just go
with that what is your personal favorite
number one Doctor Who episode you can't
even reach back into the classic era if
that's your favorite stuff so what is
your all-time number one I'm not saying
this episode necessarily was but I am
coming off such a high having finished
this yeah I write at this moment I would
say it's in contention so whatever is
yours drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it until
next time this council is adjourned